you can't have a birthday bash without a
lot of gifts so audience birthday
buddies of mine
every time you hear this sound
because i love that sound you're in for
some goodies because we're giving away
more than 100 000
worth of gifts today
it's our biggest giveaway ever
welcome back to our big birthday bash
well you know what that sound is it's
giveaway time more birthday gifts for
the birthday gang and first up my flower
beauty petal pout lip scrub and lip mask
in the shade
barrymore i scrub and mask with this all
the time i'm giving this away with total
confidence that it's going to make you
guys happy and that's so important to me
to have your back you'll never go to the
bathroom and go oh my lipstick
not on my watch
and uh where is jessica cantu by the way
surprise
hello happy birthday happy birthday to
you too thank you um we heard that you
have been on a weight loss journey yes
drew i am i've been working two jobs for
about uh three years now and so i saved
up money i took out a small loan i
emptied my savings account and i paid to
have my gastric sleeve surgery in may
2021 and i've lost 115 pounds since then
well you're an inspiration and um to
keep up with the momentum and add to
your routine we have the new hydro rower
exercise machine plus a year-long access
membership and this package is amazing
valued at over 2 500
and this is all the rage in exercise
right now because it's like such a full
body workout
um and devin's gonna demonstrate feels
good right here right now
that means this giveaway time all right
at first we made a flower themed cake
then flowers are perfect for any
birthday celebration and venus a floor
has beautiful arrangements that are
perfect for gifting so everyone in our
audience
is getting a 150 gift card
um i bet women fall into you all the
time and these flowers last a very long
time and to match we have a copy of
rebel homemaker which i wrote with pilar
valdez going to all of these
[Applause]
happy birthday to you ellen and kathy
are twins who also share our 22-22
birthday and they haven't seen each
other
and zanna's been taking care of them
throughout the show
and over the course of the hour they
have had a transformation alan and kathy
i'm you're wearing those gold and
diamond pendants from your rng
absolutely beautiful thank you yeah
they're worth that twenty six hundred
dollars
[Applause]
but maybe they also can represent a
memory that santa and i are lucky to
have with you guys and everybody memory
will never never be forgotten for sure
thank you for letting us do this with
you today
as always
[Applause]
all right
time for one more where is gillian light
right here oh my goodness
well um we heard that you turned 50
today and you're a single mom let's all
enjoy this moment because your birthday
gift actually isn't inside of this room
it's um it's outside because you're
getting a 2022 hyundai venue
[Applause]
of south brunswick new jersey which is
i'm proud to say also in the girl club
because it's a female owned and operated
dealership oh my goodness i can't
believe it
gillian happy birthday
thank you so much um for being here with
us today thank you to all of our guests
our all of our let's say it together 2
22
22.
devin goda um for showcasing our
giveaways thank you so much for doing
this with us the price is right airs
weekdays at 11 a.m eastern 10 a.m
pacific on cbs i've been watching it my
whole life and happy birthday to all of
our incredible audience members thank
you so much for choosing to spend your
time and your birthday with us we all
make this show for you so please take it
with you
[Music]
you